Joining me today is the founder for act
for America,
a New York Times bestselling author and
author of the new book rise in Defensive
Judeo Christian values and freedom.
Bridgette Gabriel,
welcome back to the Rubin report.
Thank you dave.
I'm delighted to be back with you.
I am delighted that you're here.
First off,
before we do anything else,
I was gonna wear the exact same shirt.
That's a.
That is a girly girly shirt.
I love what's going on here.
Okay,
so I had you on about maybe a year and a
half ago or so.
You were the only person in the history
of the Rubin report that you caused the
tear to to formulate in my.
I think you know exactly when it
happened.
Yeah,
so before I even let you say anything
we're throwing to the clip.
We only take care of freedom and
preserve it to the next generation,
and I am doing my part as an American,
as a brave American and the home of the
brave to make sure I follow in the
footsteps of our founding fathers and do
my part as they entrusted me with that
which they have created.
I feel it is my duty to make sure to
preserve it,
to pass it to my children and their
American children and many generations
to come.
That's why we fight.
And I am so fortunate that through this
fight,
and it is a fight for freedom,
for liberty,
for democracy,
for security,
for human rights.
I am privileged to meet the most amazing
people that I would never otherwise
meet,
like sitting here with you today.
Uh,
and meet friends that have become
lifelong friends,
literally like family to me that I would
never have otherwise met if it wasn't
doing for what I do.
So do I get depressed doing what I do?
Talking about terrorism and national
security?
Of course I do.
I'm human,
like everybody.
Sometimes I cry.
Sometimes I'm completely depressed over
things that are happening.
Sometimes I hurt deeply by people who
stabbed me in the back or say bad things
about me or even reading my wikipedia
profile.
But what keeps me so energized is the
American people and the American spirit
knowing that we are making a difference.
We are growing,
we are changing our country,
we are fighting,
we have a purpose.
So when you and I die on our deathbed,
we can look back and we can say,
I made a difference as we take our last
breath and that's enough for me.
That is how you end an interview.
I mean that's it right there.
That was,
that was like your opus right there.
Well,
because I spoke from the heart and when
you speak from the heart,
your message resonates with people and
this is exactly why people,
a you and me are having such traction
with.
A lot of people are saying we love what
you're saying.
It's about time that somebody will say
the things that you are saying,
our message is resonating and you know
why people want something genuine and
they can tell,
you know,
I always tell my children the one thing
you can never love,
you can never fight club because people
can tell when you're genuine and in a
world that we live in today where
everything is fake,
everything is about social media and how
things appear before the camera and,
and,
and what's in it for me and I'm going to
be your friend because I'm going to get
something out of it.
When people look you and I put our life
on the line because of the conviction
that we have about the truth that we are
speaking and why we are willing to go to
great extent to just fight for that
truth.
It resonates with people.
So I go to wait to be with you today.
This is great.
Why don't team
did you always have this kind of
passion?
I mean,
when you were on last time we told her,
you told your whole life story,
which is absolutely fascinating and if
you want to give me a just like a two
minute recap and we'll link to it down
below so people can watch the whole
thing if they haven't.
So if you wanna give me a little recap
on that,
but I also want to know where your,
that,
that smile,
that joy,
that presence,
where does that come from within you and
did you always have that?
I love life and I am so passionate about
life is because I lived from the age of
10 till the age of 20,
waiting to die every single day.
So every single day in my formula,
two years when I opened my eyes and I
saw sunshine outside,
I didn't know if I'm gonna live to see
the sunset.
So living in a bomb shelter,
you know,
people ask me where the specimen comes
from.
My nine slash 11 happened to me in 1975
when radical Islam is to blow up my
home,
bringing it down,
bring me under the rubble,
wounded.
I ended up in a hospital for two and a
half months and later when I came back
home,
my home was no longer the home I left.
I ended up living in this bomb shelter,
eight by 10 room underground,
no electricity,
no water,
and very little food.
And that's where I lived for seven years
of my life,
robbed of my youth,
barely interacting with people,
barely interacting with people my age.
I lived with my parents who were an
elderly couple and that bomb shelter.
So all this,
uh,
cooped up passion.
Now I tell people I'm making up for lost
time.
So I love life.
I am so grateful for life.
I'm so grateful for the people I meet,
the places I go.
I never thought I'd live the day beyond
20.
And then I never thought I'd live with
day beyond 30.
And he's loving life.
I just started 54 years old.
I'm so proud to make it someone.
Thank you.
When,
when you have survived,
as long as I have survived,
you brag about.
I made it to this day at this age.
So this is why I love life,
so we're going to link to your original
sit down and your whole story about
growing up in Lebanon and all that so
people can watch out if they haven't
seen it.
Um,
but not everybody likes you.
And I remember before I had you on the
first time,
uh,
you know,
when people google you and you even
referenced this in,
in that clip we are talking about,
you know,
if you check your wikipedia saying
people say all sorts of awful things
about you and all this,
and I was a little worried.
I was like,
ah,
it's like I'm going to have bridgette on
and I'm going to get hate for it.
And all that.
Now I'm really past that part of life.
Now I just want to do what I think is
right and I want to sit down with,
with people like you and have those
conversations.
Um,
but are you shocked at the kind of
pushback you get for defending the west
and defending Judeo Christian values?
I am no longer shocked.
I was in the beginning.
I was very hurt,
very disappointed.
I thought my message,
of course the west is going to resonate.
It's going to resonate in the west.
People are going to appreciate why it's
important to fight for freedom of
speech.
I was born and raised in Lebanon in a
country where if you stand up against
the status quo and you speak against the
regime,
you are killed.
They come take you in the middle of the
night,
killed you.
You will disappear.
You'll never hear from you again.
I still have friends who disappeared 30
years ago.
Their parents don't even know if they
are alive or dead.
Journalist and my country of birth in
Lebanon get killed for writing the wrong
thing.
So when I came to the West and when I
started speaking in defense of our
freedoms and our values and our way of
life and the American values of,
of,
you know,
standing up for the truth and speaking
the truth without having to be worried
about somebody killing you,
I could not believe people will,
will come against me like that.
But you know what?
If you don't stand for something,
yeah,
you know
you have to stand up for what you
believe.
Those are the people that make a
difference and usually people that make
a difference in this world are not
popular.
The most hated people in the.
We'll look at Churchill.
I mean,
you know,
when he was alive,
people hated him.
They thought,
oh my gosh,
you know,
look at them today.
People call people call people that has
spoken such words of wisdom,
but people left at the Monday.
We're saying them.
And so here we are today.
We stand up and we fight.
And it doesn't matter what people say
about me,
I do it what I believe is right because
I believe we are on a mission to save
Western civilization,
which is under attack right now.
And I'm wanting to do my part to make it
happen
is part of the problem of the West now
is that we don't have enough stories
like yours because we've had it pretty
good in the West for the last,
you know,
50 some odd years.
Certainly in the United States.
We've had a pretty good here,
so we've sort of gotten fat and lazy on
freedom.
We don't know what we're fighting for.
We don't know what are the generations
before us lived through.
You lived through something,
so then you come here and then you see
all these people that are slowly eroding
their freedoms and you're like,
Whoa,
I know what this.
Where this leads.
Exactly.
My past is America's future.
Unless America wakes up today,
see I am the end.
Frank who lived to tell about it.
Can you imagine if Anne Frank was alive
and the Nazis were spreading worldwide
and she just escaped the concentration
camps and she came to the United States
and not csm was started rising in the
United States.
She would be saying the same words that
you when she was alive and well.
In my case.
I started speaking after the attacks on
nine slash 11 on the United States.
I started speaking about the threat of
radical Islam to world peace in our
national security,
but because Americans had it so easy,
they cannot fathom that some people
could hate us so much.
Even though radical Islamic terrorists
hijacked airplanes and use them as a
human missiles,
flying them into skyscrapers with the
intention of killing not 3000,
but maybe 50,000
that worked in that building,
you know,
if they were late only 15 minutes,
they would have killed tens of thousands
of Americans.
Um,
and so this is what I was talking about,
but Americans are such good people.
People who have never experienced the
type of terrorism that I lived under
cannot relate and think that somebody
could be that bad,
that actually that's the real intention
to kill as many people as possible.
How do you wake people up to that then?
Because it's a really hard.
Because not everyone can have the lived
experience that you've had.
You don't have to wake all the people
up.
You just have to wake some of the people
You just have to wake up the passionate
I,
you know,
and my book rise,
I say two percent of the passionate will
always rule the 98 percent in different
and doesn't take money to change the
world.
Don't percent of the passionate will
always rule the 98 percent in different.
You just need to get people who are
fired up for your cause.
You need to get people who actually
understand the problem and get the
problem and want to do something to
change the world.
Those are the people you need to rally
around you.
Those are the people who are gonna make
a difference in this world and those are
the people that I,
that I try to communicate with.
And because of that I was able to build
an organization,
act for America.
I'm proud to tell you that we are now
over 1 million members and it's
incredible.
We have chapters nationwide.
We have passed bills,
$100 bills on the federal level as well
as the state level to protect America.
So when people tell me,
don't you worry about the names.
I mean people call you names,
you know,
they,
they will make you look bad.
They were on the list.
The SLPC SPLC has called me and white
supremacy.
How do you like those white supremacists
clips and the white supremacists skin?
And this white supremacist hair,
um,
but I tell people when people slap
labels on you,
it's because they cannot argue with your
facts.
That's why the only thing they can do is
call you names.
They cannot debate you on the facts.
And you know,
I,
I tell people all the time,
don't worry about the labels and don't
worry about the haters than New York
Times.
And my last book,
they must be stopped.
The book came out in September of 2008
that York Times interviewed me and they
couldn't find one quote and my article.
So what did they do?
They titled the Article Radical
Islamophobe,
not just an Islamophobe.
I am a radical Islamophobe.
Can you imagine if I would have let that
stop me because I was hurt that somebody
didn't like me.
And that will be a radical Islamophobia
instead of hiding under a table.
You know,
trying to kind of pat my emotions.
I went there and continue doing exactly
what I do best since 2008 till today.
My organization has helped pass $100
bills.
And that's why I tell people,
don't let the naysayers and those to
slap labels on you,
stop you,
keep on moving forward.
What do you make of these leftist
organizations,
whether it's SPLC or the ato or now in
the media,
the New York Times that are actually
empowering the very ideologies that
would love to take away all of their
freedoms.
And in this way,
I mean it's,
you've got this sort of,
you've got the progressive's basically
in bed with the Islamists and to me it's
like they're just sort of willful idiots
or there's probably some other
pejorative.
Exactly.
You know,
and my book cries,
I have a whole chapter titled the
leftists Islamists Coalition Because
that's exactly what we are seeing right
now.
Coming together.
The enemy of my enemy is my friend.
So we are seeing two people that do not
agree with anything that we say,
do not believe in American
exceptionalism.
Do not believe that America shouldn't
have strong borders.
Do not believe that we know that we need
to have a national identity.
We need to.
I mean,
securing our border,
meaning securing and protecting our
national identity.
They did not believe in borders.
They do not believe in language.
They want to bring America down to the
parts of the rest of the world.
You know,
America is equaled was Venezuela.
No one is better than anybody.
All societies are created equal uni that
even though people are created equal in
the eyes of God,
societies are not created equal.
And so what we are seeing right now is
leftist organizations working with the
Islamic.
So you've got organizations like the
Hclu,
the southern poverty law center,
planned parenthood a move on that or
working with people like Linda Sarsour
who is a devout Islamist,
a proponent of Sharia law and working
with people like her or with care
counsel on American Islamic Relations.
The acl is basically the legal arm of
the council on American Islamic
Relations.
So do you think they realize what's
going on here?
This is the part that I'm always sort of
because I don't like impugning people's
motives.
Right?
So it's like,
do they realize that they're working
with people who once they have the power
will gladly cut them out?
No,
they don't.
They just don't.
They don't.
Because people that work for the ACL,
you people that work for a,
a different leftist organizations have
good hearts,
they love America and they cannot
believe that people couldn't be bad or
people couldn't use them for their end
goal.
You know,
when I talk about the Muslim Brotherhood
project and you and I have talked about
the Muslim Brotherhood project and our
previous interview,
people need to go watch that interview
with me.
Everybody watching us right now,
they need to go back and watch that
previous interview.
Um,
the Muslim Brotherhood wrote a plan and
100 year plan for radical Islam to
infiltrate and dominate the west and
established a stomach government on
earth.
What makes the plan so unique,
especially the plan for the United
States,
for the destruction of America.
The last page of the plan for America,
let's 29 front Islamic organizations set
up in the United States with the
specific purpose of sabotage in America
and destroying it from within.
Many of these organizations that I
mentioned,
Isna,
Islamic Society of North America,
the MSA Muslim Students Association
care,
which started as iap.
Islamic Association for Palestine later
became care because they wanted to
create another name because the FBI was
on their tail knowing that they are a
Hamas in the United States.
Those are the names mentioned.
So what we're seeing right now is people
like the Hclu move on.org.
The southern poverty law center are
basically used as the useful idiots at
the hands of an Islamist with an agenda.
So while I am very upset at how the Adl
or the SPLC or the acl EU is taking the
side of Islam as the against people like
me,
I'm not sure what they say about you,
but I know they hate my guts.
Yeah.
And so I see that and it's sad to
realize that their good intentions are
being used to do something better at the
end,
but they don't realize it at this point.
Meanwhile,
they're working with the Islam is
against people like me who basically are
trying to warn against the same people
are going to destroy them at the end and
that's why
the question that way because I don't
like attacking people's motives and I
believed that if we were to sit down
with all of the people at the Acl,
you,
that the vast majority of them are
totally doing all of these things for
what they believe to be the the right
reasons,
and yet they've been just sort of
tricked into having some really unholy
alliance.
Look,
the southern poverty law center,
uh,
the same thing.
They started as a good organization
fighting the Klu Klux Klan doing
something good that was a result of
that.
They raised money.
They found the Ku Klux Klan and the
client deserves to be in a whole because
we in America will never ever tolerate
such true hatred.
But for them right now to slap the
label,
hate on anybody speaks the truth or do
not agree with their point of view.
What my heart is the.
I never judge anybody's heart.
I am the same way.
You never know.
People would ask me about a Barack
Obama.
Do you think he's a Muslim?
You know I cannot judge anybody's heart.
I don't know who he prays for.
I didn't know what's between him and his
God is God.
That's what he does and the privacy of
his own home and I will never judge
where he stands and a lot of people on
the right,
they didn't even like me saying those
words,
but that's the truth.
I will never judge what's in somebody's
heart or what's in somebody's mind.
I judged them by their actions.
So now when people slept labels on me,
oh,
she's a hater.
You don't even know me.
You have never even sat down with me and
talked me.
How can you slap a label and emotional
label on somebody that you don't even
know
if you're a hater,
you're seriously much better actress
than hater because you got me fooled,
lady.
I.
I'm telling you.
I mean,
you know,
sad to see that coming from them and
they're not listening to whatever
explanation or even when we reach out to
them,
they don't want to talk to us.
They don't want to hear our side of the,
of the view is like they judged us in
antia and that is that,
you know,
speaking of judging and obscenity,
yet they are no better than the
terrorists in Lebanon.
You know,
I went to Israel this year and a visit
with my parents' grave.
I do not know if you know,
my parents are bird with Oscar Schindler
and Mount Zion.
And so this was the first time.
Tell people how you ended up in Israel
after leaving Lebanon.
Well,
I left Lebanon.
I ended up moving to Israel,
becoming these anchor for world news and
working in Jerusalem.
And when my parents died,
I wanted to make sure that I burned them
in Israel because I wanted to make sure
that my children yet unborn will always
know where my loyalty lies.
And because I'm a firm believer that
actions speak louder than words.
So I wanted to make sure I honor my
parents because I adore my parents.
This is a very sensitive subject with
me.
Uh,
I'm an only child.
I worship my parents.
I live every single day of my life doing
everything I do to honor them and their
legacy and you know,
speaking of hatred,
some former employer did me wrong when I
was 22 years old and I remember sitting
on my father's lap and he's wheelchair
hugging him.
I was crying and I said,
Oh Daddy,
I just hate them.
I can't believe they did this to us.
And my father said to me,
he said,
I never,
ever want to hear that word coming out
of your mouth.
I never raised you to hate.
And if for nothing else because of the
way I adore my father,
at that day,
at 22 years old,
I vowed I will never hate somebody.
My father died like two weeks later.
I will never,
ever allow hate to enter my heart
towards my enemies,
towards anybody.
I don't hate anybody.
So when my parents died,
I buried them in Jerusalem.
They are buried with Oscar Schindler and
Mount Zion.
We're actually later he was brought in
and buried next to them.
So this year I went back to Lebanon to
Israel,
and because I cannot go to Lebanon,
Hezbollah wants me dead.
So I go to Israel.
I visited Israel,
I meet with the idea of I actually was
the first Lebanese person to ever make
it to the rooftop of the IDF
headquarters in Tel Aviv,
and I recorded videos with the
spokesperson of the IDF and with the top
generals were recorded videos to be
broadcast to the United Nations,
to the international community video to
be broadcast to Lebanon about how,
why we need to work together towards
peace,
why we need to love each other.
Potato aside,
forget what you're thought about the
Jews.
Israel doesn't want anything but peace
with its neighbors.
Let's work together on peace.
And for that,
Hezbollah aired that on Lebanese
television they charged me with treason.
Now I am wanted that in Lebanon and
sentenced to death by hanging in to.
So here we have a group of terrorists in
my home country of Lebanon who judged me
and who I am,
and I deserve to be sentenced to death
by hanging because they did not agree
with me preaching a message of love
about being friends with the Jews.
So here we have them calling me haters
and yet I have the leftist in America,
the southern poverty law center,
and these people calling me haters
simply because I'm warning about the
Islamic terrorist threat.
All right,
well you've got too much good in you to
focus on the haters.
But I do have one other question about
the haters and then we're gonna just put
it behind us,
which is when marginalized sued the
southern poverty law center.
Now he's been removed from their anti
Muslim extremists list.
And you were on there still as far as I
know.
Is I on still on there?
Actually that.
Yeah,
yeah.
Still a over there.
Of course.
Are you kidding?
Oh,
Linda Sarsour.
Once you're A.
Yeah.
Well once my private parts removed,
Ms Dot women's feminist movement,
you know,
um,
but that the world is turned upside
down.
So we are still on that list,
um,
sitter or a lawsuit or anything because
I'm not generally for lawsuits in these
cases,
but it magic proved that if they've
really wronged you and you can get the
backing to get the lawyers to do it,
that ultimately justice does prevail.
We talk to our attorneys to sue them and
it's going to cost a lot of money and
they can drag it for years and years and
years have gotten onto 90 attorneys on
staff.
Well,
we have to depend on the generosity of
attorneys to do with pro bono.
They get dragged out forever.
Plus because I'm a public person and the
head of an organization that will get us
into discovery,
which means they not only can't subpoena
me,
which I don't say anything,
but I'm not worried,
but they can go after my chapters and
any communications our chapters have
done with their friends.
Now our chapters are completely
independent.
Their members are completely
I don't even know who they are.
So if somebody sent a personal email to
a third party mentioning any worried
about,
hey,
which we are completely not responsible
for because they don't speak about
headquarters,
they can say,
see,
we told you they've got people that
tight.
And so because I do not know three,
four levels down,
see Nash,
it doesn't have a national organization.
Definitely not was chapters and members
of the way we do.
So he's only responsible for what he
says.
I can fight and defend what I say,
but I cannot fight and defend what
people don't.
I don't even know.
Look,
the SPLC went after us and they said,
oh,
we've got white supremacist.
You know who show up to our rallies.
Round is on the side street corner.
Anybody can stand on the side street
corner or you know the.
You cannot say that these members belong
to my organization,
but they do.
And that's the tactic of the left right
now.
Alright,
let's focus on
the book.
So the subtitle is in Defensive Judeo
Christian values and freedom.
So just most simply,
if someone said to you what our Judeo
Christian values,
what are they,
what are the most fundamental,
Judeo Christian values that we need?
No.
Well,
do they have Christian values are the
bedrock of Western civilization.
They are the foundation of what we have
today in America.
And this is not a religious book at all.
You read it,
you endorsed it.
It's not a religious one of the most
fundamental freedoms.
I'll give you a perfect example.
Freedom of speech.
People don't realize where that freedom
comes from.
You know,
and Israel,
the Hasidic Jews,
they debate the Bible.
They 24 hours a day.
That's all they do.
They debate the Bible and what does that
come from?
The Bible says,
come,
let us reason together means let's
debate ideas.
I may not like your idea.
You may not like mine and we could have
five other people who make look at the
same verse completely differently,
but the reason why we debate ideas is
because we can learn from each other and
butter.
Understand what statements mean were the
author who wrote that statement meant by
it.
We all know that God didn't write the
Bible.
People wrote the Bible,
so part of our fundamental way of
thinking,
the freedom of speech,
the ability to come together and debate
ideas and passionately debate these
ideas,
yet agreed to respectfully disagree and
walk away.
People don't realize that comes from the
foundation of today,
a Christian Foundation.
You know,
even people who are not religious
understand.
That's so uniquely Western.
You know,
they don't do that.
And,
and,
and the Islamic world for example,
you don't debate ideas.
Why?
Because in the car and the Qur'an was
written,
it's the word of God.
It's not debatable.
It's not negotiable.
You can not look back.
You can add change versus you don't even
talk about it.
You can even question it very different
than the way we are.
So when I write in the book about,
and I actually,
I have a chapter titled The deaths of
Free Speech,
more.
I talk about how we are losing our
ability to speak the truth because then
your label,
your biggest people are afraid.
Am I going to be blackmailed?
Am I going to be boycotted the by going
to lose my job?
Um,
and so it's,
we're silencing ourselves and that's why
I titled the Book Rise,
rise in defensive,
Judeo Christian values and freedom
because we're losing those freedoms,
those American values before our very
eyes.
Are you watching this chip away more in
Europe than in the United States right
now?
For All our problems around this.
And I agree it,
the bigger problem right now is that
we're silencing ourselves rather than
the government coming to silence us.
Although that could potentially be a
problem in the future.
I don't sense.
It's a huge problem right now.
Europe has a whole other set of problems
around free speech.
Do you think that they're more suited to
lose faster because they don't have a
first amendment the way we do?
Oh yeah.
That are far
more advanced than losing their rights
and their freedoms than we are.
And they did it by self censorship.
You know,
I landed the lung than I will speaking
in London in 2007.
So I land in London.
I'm a standing there waiting for my
luggage with the.
I'm a pilot and the hostess is,
uh,
we were in a private section and they
said,
oh,
what are you doing here?
And I said,
Oh,
I'm just here for like three days.
I'm giving a speech and parliament that
was speaking to the,
uh,
British parliament.
And they said,
oh,
what are you going to be talking about?
And I said,
the threat of radical Islam to world
peace and national security and all of a
sudden silence for 30 seconds you could
hear a pin drop.
They didn't know how to react to what to
say.
They were so afraid to react less.
Somebody hears something.
That backseat driver,
my driver picked me up to drive me to my
hotel and we were talking in the car and
I told them,
you asked me again,
what are you doing here?
And I said the same thing.
He said,
Bridgette,
in 10 years I believe we're going to
have blood on the streets of London by
radical Islamists.
We are at war.
And it didn't even take 10 years.
Within five years we're already started
seeing stabbing on the streets of London
and stuff like that.
So in Europe they are afraid to talk
about it and they do not have the
freedom of speech that we have and
that's why it's so important to defend
the freedom of speech that we have and
God bless them.
Our founding fathers would,
there was them,
they knew exactly what they were doing.
I mean,
look,
remember they came from Europe,
so when they wrote us what they gave us
the constitution and our bill of rights
and all of that stuff,
they knew exactly why they put some of
these amendments at there.
So.
Alright,
so let's just put a Europe aside.
Since we're in the United States,
they're going to have to deal with that.
We'll deal with it here.
Um,
okay.
We can get people to rise.
But what else do we have to do to have a
discussion about this that's going to
stop the people that are going to use
all of those labels.
So I know even in the book you make a
point of saying,
of course this is not all Muslims and
don't be bigoted towards Muslim.
People were talking about an ideology,
a lot of people have been doing that for
the last couple of years,
tried to separate people from ideas and
all that and still get all the labels
thrown at them.
What are some of the other techniques we
can use to talk about these things and
not be crushed by by all the labor.
Don't waste your breath because there is
nothing you can say at this point.
No matter what you say,
the enemy,
the SPLC,
the Adl,
move on that or organizing for action.
All the progressive organizations,
they're not willing to listen to you.
They don't want to listen to you.
Look,
we organized a march against sharia,
March for human rights last year,
a year and a half ago,
and we had rallies in 29 cities in 21
states and we timed put the pulse
nightclub bombing and Florida because it
was June 10th.
We wanted to shine a light about the
hatred of this ideology against gays.
What they do to gays.
I mean,
look at the pulse nightclub bombing.
The people organize our rallies in New
York.
It was organized and headed by two gay
guys.
The rally in Atlanta was headed by a
Muslim man.
Do we had an emom speaking in Seattle.
We had Miriam Abrahim,
the so then he's survivors.
Speak at that rally in Virginia beach as
well as an Iranian Muslim leader of the
Iranian movement,
you know,
to to,
to,
to avoid from the mullahs.
Did you think any of the media covered
any of that?
All they did.
They show up on the street corner,
say no.
It's say no to say no to it.
They didn't even bother understand what
we were doing.
So don't waste your breath right now.
People tell me,
why are you speaking to the choir?
Bridget?
We need to talk to other people at this
time.
You need to mobilize the choir because
when you need your house cleaned,
it is the choir that shows up.
It is the choir that brings you food.
When you're sick,
it is the choir that mops the church or
the temple when it needs cleaning.
It's the choir that brings the flowers
and that's all that matters to keep your
house up and keep it protected,
and that's why right now,
don't waste your breath on the labels.
Make sure you fight.
Make sure you lobby our elected
officials.
Make sure you understand the power of
the gavel,
why it is important to call your elected
officials.
You know in my book what makes this book
so unique is at the end of every
chapter,
I have a section titled Dries Up and act
where I give people ideas,
so I want to do all that at the end.
I want all.
I want all of your absolute advice on
this,
but what you hit on something that I
think is really interesting there.
There's a connection to all of this and
the way the media reports.
Yeah,
you're right,
that when they cover your events or when
they cover,
a lot of the.
The people that I'm friends with that I
have on the show,
whatever they say,
it's like they only focus on the haters.
They only focus on the one little
outsider that's,
that's doing something that's bad and
not on all the good.
How,
how do you think this happened to the
media or is there a way that it can be
fixed or does it need to burn to the
ground or what?
Because the progressive media is not
interested in dialogue.
They are interested in winning.
See,
we are on the conservative side,
you know,
and it's such a shame.
I never thought of myself as a
conservative.
I mean,
I don't know if I voted for Al Gore.
I was a proud democrat.
Nine slash 11,
you know,
conservative as they call us
conservative.
Uh,
but this is where we are in our nation
right now.
They consider people like you
conservative because you speak about,
you know,
important issues that are now known as,
oh,
that's what the conservatives talk
about,
you know.
So what we are seeing right now is the
media is interested in winning.
Well,
we are interested in having a dialogue.
How can we get through to them?
How can we speak with them,
you know,
and,
and find the bridge where we can talk to
them about that they're not interested
in talking to us.
They're interesting in silencing our
voices and the sooner we know that the
better we are in fighting our battle and
learning how to win our battle.
And you add to that funders like
sorrows,
you know,
and my book,
I have a whole section about Soros and
hadn't funding the media source right
now has spent.
Doesn't that mean,
do you have an anti Semite if you talk
about Soros,
that's their new meme.
I didn't even know he was Jewish until
about a year ago.
Right.
And everything he does is usually
against Israel and the height of
stupidity.
Uh,
I mean,
you know,
you would think he sounds like an anti
semite much more than me.
Remember,
he is the one who works with the
doctors,
with the Nazis on,
on,
um,
actually had a smile when people ask
them,
how did you feel about going in and
working with the Nazis against your own
people?
He said,
well,
you know,
somebody had to do it.
So I know I to say any problem with it,
you know,
you're not making that up either way.
No,
no.
I mean,
I watched his interview because I was
very interested on what makes this man
the way he is.
I studied my enemies,
uh,
I spend a lot of hours actually studying
my enemies,
uh,
to understand how they think,
why,
why do they behave,
you know,
trying to pick up on cues.
So you look at somebody like George
Soros,
who is interested in transforming
America into his vision of how the world
should be and he has the billions and
he's willing to spend that $43 billion
has already been spent on the media,
on Soros funded media,
um,
and the teas from,
uh,
since 2002.
And so when you look today at Soros has
tentacles that extend to a 33 media
outlets including ABC,
NBC,
CBS,
MSNBC,
the Washington Post Associated Press,
which I detail in my book.
Uh,
even though the,
to give you an example,
which I thought that the book,
Columbia School of Journalism gave them
$600,000
to their journalism school because he
wanted to impact the reporting on how
reporters report on the media issues in
the future.
So nobody was paying attention to this
stuff.
But this is exactly how we ended up with
reporters who are no longer reporters.
They are activists with a national
platform media platform.
Whoa.
Get on television every night and
basically pure the same pocket political
points approved by Soros and they all
say the same thing,
whether it's the Huffington Post,
the New York Times,
the Associated Press,
Reuters,
MSNBC,
CNBC,
ABC,
the same buzzword and it's all
coordinated.
How concerned are you that on the social
media front where people like you have
been able to make gains?
You know,
I'll see every now and again you'll talk
about,
oh,
I just suddenly lost 5,000
followers on twitter or something like
that.
That we're fighting a losing battle on
that front.
Ultimately because these companies are.
I think there are a lot of political
connections and who knows what's going
on behind the scenes,
but be,
they've basically embraced the leftist
ideology and they're not really around
to make sure that bridgette Gabriel's
voice can be heard.
Well,
we lose followers by the tens of
thousands,
tens of thousands,
and we are seeing that happen,
especially now at a dramatic pace.
Uh,
but you continue on doing what you are
doing.
Is it,
there is nothing you can do to change
it.
Uh,
you just continue pushing.
We are working with members of Congress
to make sure that there's fairness and
reporting and that the government will
intervene to make sure that we don't
have a monopoly look.
They did the same thing with
Microsoft's.
Remember Microsoft data monopoly.
The government had to intervene and they
said,
no,
you cannot stop anybody else who wants
to develop computers.
Apple didn't have a chance if the
government didn't intervene with
Microsoft.
So we know that there is precedent,
but here is the secret to success.
My Libertarian brain,
all the bells go off on that stuff
though because I don't want the
government to do it.
It's like for me,
it's like be last resort,
even though I know that this is
obviously a very personal issue to me as
someone that puts this up on youtube and
the rest of them
we want fairness.
We're not telling them silence anybody,
but we are saying to them,
allow people to speak their mind.
You know,
if I owned a media platform and I do not
agree with you at all in what you say,
as an American,
I will bite my tongue and grit my teeth
and listen to what I absolutely
passionately opposed.
I'm not saying you,
but anybody you know,
you could be saying,
you know what,
whoever,
but I will fight for your right to do
it.
I will not silence you because it is an
American to silence you.
So as Americans we owe it to each other
at least to defend these,
right?
So we can so we can pass them out.
Our Future generations.
You never really own freedom,
David.
We only preserve it for the future
generation.
And I said that statement with you
before and I actually have it going all
throughout my book.
These are the rights that our founding
fathers gave everything and most of them
died broke to give us these rights that
we have today.
The least we can do is preserve it for
the next generation.
That's all we're asking for.
But you know the secret to success
regardless of how much the social media
puts you on facebook jail or twitter
bands,
your shadow,
betty,
etc.
Tenacity,
tenacity,
tenacity.
You keep on pushing.
You keep on pushing and you never,
ever,
ever give up.
That is the secret to success.
I appreciate we've talked for about 35
minutes.
We have not said the two words.
Donald trump.
First up,
I think we just had a record 35 minutes
of conversation without saying once.
Okay.
You are a trump supporter.
I'm a trumpeteer dear.
Okay.
You're a trumpet tier.
I think you've met with the president,
right?
Yes.
Um,
how does.
Well,
what?
Can you tell me something about him
maybe that the average person doesn't
know or that you might not get through
the filter of cnn or that you maybe
don't even get through the filter of
twitter.
He is somebody,
he is a billionaire who left the life of
luxury to serve the american people.
He is somebody who is not doing it for
power.
He already had power.
He's not doing it for fame.
He already had fame.
He's not doing it for the money.
He already had money.
He doesn't care.
He wakes up every morning to all the
insults and the hate and images of
beheading by cathy griffith.
That's his can watch and be mortified
that somebodY actually really killed my
dad.
And then he remembers I'm not doing this
to police the media.
I'm doing it because I'm fighting for
the american people.
They hate him.
Not because,
um,
they hate him because he is serving the
american people.
He is putting America first and they do
not know how to handle him.
And that's why Donald Trump is
resonating with a lot of people in this
country,
from ceos of companies to janitors
working for $10 an hour because from the
janitor to the ceo,
they know.
And everybody in between.
President Donald Trump is working for
me.
And it's a breath of fresh air because
for decades now we have had manY
presidents on the right and the left,
not many people could say,
barack obama's working for me,
or George Bush is working for me,
are clinton is working for me,
but with Donald Trump,
the janitor knows president Donald Trump
is working for me and that's why he's
resonating with the people.
So when You see the tweets and some of
the over the top stuff,
every now and again I'll watch some old
clips from him in the eighties talking
to oprah or phil donahue and he's,
he's soft and seemingly plus,
you know,
very pleasant and open and you can see
the way inq and a's with audience
members.
I think our donahue,
he's,
he's extremely human.
All of these things.
and it's not exactly the caricature that
we get these days.
Do you think that he sort of became this
thing because it was the only.
He basically was the.
It was the only way he would have been
hard enough to break through.
Does that make sense?
Like I think he was probably extremely
similar to the person from back then,
but he became hardened because it was
the only way you were going to ever
break through this like no one else was
ever going to break through this thing.
If you listen to Donald Trump,
today is the exact same person he was 25
years ago when he was on phil donahue,
when he was on oprah,
he still says the exact same words.
Have you noticed?
Or the theme is the same,
but he's.
He's hard in now.
There's like a,
and I don't.
I'm not even blaming him for that.
I think to go through this,
to go through the media machine and the
establishment and all that,
you've got to get hardened.
Otherwise it will choke everybody out,
which is what fights to win.
Before they didn't argue with what he
said,
so you didn't see that side of him.
He would have been just as hard back
then.
Today.
They did not want to listen to every
word he says.
If he became jesus,
they will find a reason to fight against
them.
They would call him,
you know,
evil hater,
monster,
whatever,
whatever.
So the reason why they call him all the
names that they call him now is because
he has not toeing the line to them.
Look,
he has 90 million followers on twitter.
He goes,
trade around the media.
He doesn't need the media.
He is communicating directly with the
american people and the media hates this
and he is somebody who fights the brand.
I love his Tweets by the way,
but it makes a lot of people
uncomfortable.
Oh my god,
I cannot believe he tweeted that.
You know what?
We finally have a man who stands up to
the bullyism punches back.
We are so used to men who are whizzes in
this country.
We have forgotten what it's like to see
a real man who stands up and says,
I respect myself too much to let you
walk all over me or call me that,
or treat me that way,
but if you treat me that way,
I'm going to punch you back.
Now.
stand up like a man and fight me.
We forgot how women like that looks
like,
and so Donald Trump is shocking the
system at a time where men have been
stripped out of their manhood.
They,
you know,
uh,
the socIety is changing,
you know,
roles are changing.
So in our society today,
they want the man that they can walk all
over and,
you know,
they say,
oh,
we need somebody who is nice and you
know,
like romney or mccain,
you know,
everybody loved mccain until he ran for
president than they did the same thing
to him.
Everybody loved wrongly until he ran for
president.
They did the same thing.
I mean,
if you would hear cnn talking about
romney or mccain when they were running
for president,
they were saying the same thing,
but he hated women.
All of those things.
So same thing.
I'm completely with you on that part.
But yeah,
that's what I mean by the hardening of
trump,
that he almost had to be this thing
because nobody else could have.
they tried it the other way.
They tried it with knight,
you know,
nicer people so to speak,
and it just doesn't work.
So it's like,
well this is,
this is the guy you're going to get.
I had his getting things done and the
american people are behind him and he is
resonating with the american people.
And if his message wasn't resonating,
he wouldn't have the tens of millions of
followers that are following them on
social media and still rooting for him.
And the Donald Trump supporters dig
their heels even deeper where the only
attacks from the media,
even the attacks from his own party.
Dave,
I mean,
look you and I know there are people who
hates his guts in Washington dc.
You talk about cleaning the swamp.
He is shaking everybody the left and the
right,
despite all that,
his support,
his approval rating is at an all time
high.
you know,
so it doesn't matter what people are
saying to him.
He is doing what is right by the
american people by America.
So what are some of the policies that
he's doing that,
that jive with this book?
Like in terms of borders and stuff like
that,
you're,
you're for building the wall.
Absolutely.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And here's Why I am an illegal immigrant
to the United States.
I understand what it's like for people
to want to come here.
I want it to come here so badly.
I remember getting an american flag,
putting it under my pillow and my bomb
shelter.
And I couldn't wait to come to America.
I learned english.
I don't know if I shared with you this
was your less time writing subtitles on
my own that I tell you.
That's how I learned english.
I never studied english at school.
I was so determined to come to the
United States that we would watch black
and white television operated on a car
battery in our bomb shelter.
And my father would watch the news and
if there was any charge of the battery
left,
I would watch the love boat on wednesday
night and dallas on friday night.
AnD you know,
we,
we would have everything sometimes.
I know,
I know that,
that that's what impacted my life.
And,
and if two people looked into each
other's eyes and you know,
he said something to her and she said
maybe,
and they would rise with maybe what met
on the bottom.
I knew that maybe meant whatever that
word in arabic.
And I would literally write it in ink on
my arm.
And because we barely had water to
drink,
let along shower.
We showered once a week.
I felt a huge victory valarie on my arm.
That's how I learned english because I
was so determined that if I ever meet an
american,
I want to be able to be able to
communicate with them in their language
so I can get to the United States.
And when I came to the United States,
uh,
I came to America by marriage.
I had married an american war
correspondent in jerusalem.
We came to America.
We put in my papers to become an
american.
I Flew here.
I paid for my airline ticket,
paid for my attorneys to do all my
paperwork,
faith for my doctor's visit to do all
the needle,
poking to make sure I'm tested for this
disease and that disease to make sure
I'm not bringing anything to the
country,
and then I had to study it through inch
thick book written by the daughters of
the american revolution about america's
history and heritage and pass a written
exam as well as a verbal exam in
english.
Before I became an american.
I bought america's history.
By the time I became an american,
I knew more about america's history than
my own american born husband.
Did I am illegal immigrant.
Those are the type of immigrants who
need coming to America because we had a
fire in our belly to be all we can be as
americans right now.
The people who are breaking the law to
get here,
not because they want to come here for a
better life or they are escaping
persecution.
Look at the care event that's coming to
the United States.
Mexico offered them asylum.
Mexico offered them jobs.
They didn't want it.
They're not there to seek jobs or
asylum,
they you and they passed literally by un
center setup specifically for those who
want asylum and claiming refugee status.
They didn't even stop continued coming
to the United States to the border and
not even to the port of entry just to
break the law gets here.
We have to have law and order in the
country,
so yes,
I support Donald Trump,
build the wall and make sure anybody who
wants to come to the United States can
go through the proper channel and earn
the privilege to be an american because
it is a privilege because people like me
who did it by the book are insulted and
offended when we see criminals are
allowed to come in here and have the
same rights that we paid with our sweat,
heart and blood to get and work very
hard for years to become americans.
That's so fascinating to me because
they've also done plenty of studies on
this.
Were
recent immigrants are actually against
the caravan and against a lot of these
people.
not because they have anything against
the people,
but if you did it the right way,
if you did it the way the law lays out,
well,
then you don't want people just just
storming over and that that is what a
nation of laws is,
right,
and you don't.
When you look at what illegal
immigration is costing the United
States,
do you know that $45,
billion dollars a year leaves America
from those illegal aliens that come here
to work in the United States,
that legal criminal aliens and they sent
it to their countries of origin.
That mOney is not staying here.
They're not here to become a part of the
american fabric to contribute to
american society,
to grow,
to become all they can be.
They are here to use our system and
siphoned money and send it out there.
Do you know that it costs the american
public $200,000,000,000
a year and welfare expenses by criminal
illegal aliens to the United States.
3 million illegal aliens are
incarcerated dailY in american prisons.
Thirty percent of federal inmates in
federal prisons are illegal criminal
aliens.
So when you look at the cost,
when you add all the costs,
and I can rattle in a bunch of points,
but when you add it all up,
$338,000,000,000
a year is the cost of illegal
immigration to the United States.
The cost to build the wall is nothing
compared to what we're paying annually
and a lift illegal criminal aliens.
Not to mention the crimes killing our
children,
[inaudible] gangs coming here and what
they're doing to our society.
We don't want any of that.
What do you make of the same people who
will tell you that America is an evil
patriarchal capitalist,
that monster that also want open borders
to apparently share in that horror with
everybody else.
AmerIca pretty,
pretty flawed.
Thinking there would absolutely.
America is the most incredible nation on
the face of the planet.
Look,
you traveled the world.
You're traveling on a speaking tour.
I was born and raised on the other side
of the world.
I understand you and I have traveled the
world.
I mean from Australia to europe.
I mean we've been on a lot of places.
You went on and we have seen how the
other,
the rest of the world lives compared to
the rights that we have here.
LOok,
our poorest of the poor who are living
on welfare,
have dishwashers in their government,
paid housing,
have heating and air conditioning,
have cell phones.
you know,
these are luxury items and many other
places in the rest of the world.
Even in developed countries that are
considered luxurY items.
This is what we give to people who are
living on welfare in the United States.
So those will complain about America
need to open their eyes.
They need to go to India.
You go to the slums of India,
they need to visit the Philippines.
They need to go to Vietnam.
They need to go to Egypt.
They need to see how the rest of the
world lives and then come back to
America and complain.
Isn't it just a lazy way of thinking
really?
Because it's just easier to destroy than
create,
so it's just easier to sit after all of
the hard one freedoms and tell you how
horrible everything is rather than
actually fix anything but burning things
down.
There's a lot easier,
right?
Exactly,
exactly.
And they uh,
and,
but no one's holding them accountable.
You see people like us and the old grade
generation who really fought world war
two,
who are the veterans are still lying
among us today.
Whoa.
Fought In the wars,
whether in Korea or in Vietnam or world
war two.
I mean now they're getting older and
fewer undying but their descendants.
So understand what America did to the
world and the freedoms that we helped
spread around the world.
Look,
we didn't want anything from the Japan.
We conquered nation and then we gave
them their freedom and then rebuilt
them.
who does that?
We didn't go to Iraq because we wanted
oil.
We didn't go to Afghanistan because we
wanted the oil.
We went there and started building
schools on bridges for them to improve
their lives and left and didn't take any
of the oil with us.
We want to improve the world and we need
the fight right now.
Those lazy american brats who are
speaking ills of America,
who do not understand the America.
We need to come together,
organize and rise,
rise together in defense of America,
and that's why we need to come together
and understand what we are facing,
how we are losing our country.
And this is what I get to in the book.
You know,
I say,
how did we go from the stories of George
Washington and the cherry tree?
I shall never tell a lie.
How did we go from that generation to
the antifa thug?
So we're born and raised in America,
went to american schools,
paid for bY our tax dollars.
Who believe you can cheat,
you can lie,
you can still,
you can show up with machetes,
you uh,
and,
and brass knuckles.
YoU can hit people,
you can block bridges,
you can destroy property and you feel
justified doing it.
How do we go in one generation and what
lifetime from this to that.
And that's why we need to stand up.
Those of us who are in the middle who
understand America greatness need to
come together and stand up to fight to
protect America while we still have a
chance.
So what are the other judeochristian
values that we need to be thinking
about?
We talked about free speech.
What are the other bedrock principles
that we need to fight back some of this
stuff.
Oh my goodness,
we need to fight to protect our
language.
Explained something very easy to you.
You we cannot lose our language.
Language unites people in one nation,
the english language right now,
we are importing people from different
parts of the world and we are not making
them learn english.
We now have public schools that have 16
different languages that are spoken in a
public school and teachers will have to
be trained to,
to speak a certain language to children
instead of saying,
okay,
no,
you came to America,
you need to assimilate to need to learn
english.
I know spanish people who have been in
this country,
mexican people for over 20 years,
they still cannot speak english properly
or they speak very little english.
That's not acceptable.
That's not what made America great.
We have got to enforce that english is
the official language of the United
States and shall remain.
So we welcome people from all
backgrounds.
The immigrants that came to this country
back,
the jews that came from all over the
world,
the irish catholics,
they,
everybody,
they came to the United States.
They made sure their children spoke
english because they wanted their kids
to become as american as apple pie,
as fast as possible to assimilate into
the society.
We're not seeing that right now.
We are seeing in detroit,
you call government the office,
you're getting in arabic,
you know,
and then you push like forfor english,
arabic,
and then you got spanish and then you
get this and this and that.
That's unacceptable and people need to
understand their power.
And my book,
at the end of every chapter,
I have a section title dries up and act.
No matter what I'm talking about,
I give people ideas and tips.
Three things you can do under 10 minutes
that will make a difference for the
country and you can do them slipping
your cup of coffee in your pajamas at
7:00
AM in the morning to give you an idea,
calling your elected official.
Many people say,
bridgette,
what is my voice going to count?
My eleCted official needs to hear from
40,000
people before they do something wrong.
I talked to elected officials all the
time and I asked them,
how many people do you need to hear from
about a single issue to make it your top
priority?
You'll be shocked.
How many do you think?
I mean it's got to be so ridiculously
low because nobody calls them and we all
think it's 40,000,
but it's probably like 50 people or
something.
That's it.
Forty to 50 people and here is the
science behind the numbers.
They believe if one person makes a phone
call or writes a letter,
he or she are representing $1,000,
but they those who feel the same way but
are too lazy to make a phone call or
write a letter.
Yet they vote on election day.
That translates to 40 to 50,000
voters on election day.
That can make or break an election.
So I tell people,
you can be active sitting in traffic.
I look,
we are in la.
How many hours do you spend sitting in
traffic?
I spent two and a half hours yesterday
sitting in traffic trying to go 50 miles
program,
the white house phone number program,
your elected officials phone number in
your,
in your,
uh,
cell phone when you get a text alert
from us about a bill coming down for a
vote,
punch a button,
click and call your elected officials,
or send an email.
When people go to act for america.org,
which I mentioned all throughout the
book,
my organization act for America,
that org,
they can click on contact congress.
They can sign up to get our emails and
action alerts.
We send emails about bill's coming down
for a vote.
The bill number,
who sponsors it,
what it says.
We even have pre written letters for
them that they can email their elected
officials with the click of a button.
It'll go to your elected official
letters to the editors and script.
I give samples in this book.
The last chapter,
the whole chapter is samples about
activism samples about letters to the
editor.
all you have to do is add your name and
send it to your newspaper.
As part of the problem that we put so
much emphasis on the presidency,
so it's great.
You're doing local activism.
You're saying call your congressman if
you've got a problem with your exit.
My exit right here where I live,
I don't want to say exactly where it's
filled with garbage for the two years
that I've been living here,
david's been calling this guy nonstop to
get the.
He wants to go out there and start
picking up stuff,
but it's too dangerous,
but it's just.
But like nobody focuses on local anymore
because we put such emphasis on the
executive branch,
on the cult of personality around the
presidency.
So it's like by going to your local
congressman or congresswoman,
you might actually get something done.
It's a lot harder to do it the other
way.
Absolutely.
And and on the local elected offiCials,
you kNow,
your local,
state aNd delegates,
I may have you called the guy at the 12
people.
That's it.
And so this is why we started chapters
nationwide.
This is why we have activists
I tell people,
go to act for America.
That org sign up as an activist.
Joined a chapter or started chapter,
there's a chapter near you.
Everything happens on a local level
because those local elected officials
that you develop a connection with,
an eye contact,
go to become state elected officials.
Then federal elected officials,
attorney generals,
and then state senators,
congressmen.
This is how we change society and so I
encourage people to get involved and
become engagement.
That's exactly what this book is a
roadmap for people on how to rise,
rise this title that dries,
you know,
people need to get this book and they
need to donate it to every library in
their community.
So when people are looking to find out
information,
they can find it.
Read it for yourself,
donate it to a public library in your
community,
get multiple copies.
We want people to learn how they can be
mobilized.
The left understands how to mobilize.
We on the right,
understand the issues,
but do not know how to mobilize.
And that's what this book teaches them.
So what?
What else?
What else can we do?
I feel like you got a couple of other
tricks up your sleeve.
Oh,
absolutely.
Sexy.
It can't just be calling your
congressman,
make new friends,
find out,
start a chapter,
you'll get to meet the great new friends
in your community.
If people sign up to be a chapter leader
with us,
we will connect them with the same group
in their local community who sign up for
our emails and they say,
I want to join a chapter.
I want to meet people in my community
like this.
We connect them together.
They can do local activities together.
They can go out to dinners together.
They can work on issues relating to
their community.
I have found I have made the best
friends doing my activism.
That's what launched my career in
activism.
So this is the type of ideas that people
can do.
Come together and work together.
Have on a saturday,
one saturday,
I have a meeting,
a chapter meeting once a month,
write letters to your congressman about
the garbage on the side of the street.
You know,
we need to clean this garbage out.
This is unacceptable.
A probe test builds up or coming down.
I'll give you an idea.
We're accepting all these refugees
coming in here,
so right now we are bringing our
standards down to accommodate the
standards of people from third world
country.
To give you an example,
the city of denver in 2017 passed an
ordinance that allowed people to on the
sidewalk.
Why?
because they have a lot of illegal
immigrants who feel no problem to just
drop their pants and do it on the side
of the road,
but because it is a deportable crime,
because that crime is punishable up to
one year in jail and if you commit such
a crime,
you are deported.
The city of denver has a bigger problem
with illegal immigration than san
francisco and philadelphia,
so that's why they passed the ordinance.
They did not want people deported.
Can you imagine if you have a chapter
with 30 people or 30 people organizing
together on the same issue,
calling your local state government
saying,
this is unacceptable and if you don't
change that,
we're going to vote you out and replace
you.
That's how the left does it.
That's how we need to do it.
That's a pretty clear one where you
could probably escape some of the cries
of racism,
right,
because nobody wants their streets
filled up with pooper.
You know,
san francisco has this app that'll tell
you where human poop is
unbelievable and now that diseases that
are spreading because of that,
and this is something I mentioned in the
book,
all the rise in diseases in our country,
you know,
you've heard right now,
but the lyme disease or that disease
that's not being transferred to people
because in san francisco you've got
flies basically eating that human waste
and then you're walking down the street
and they're biting you,
so mosquitoes now are transferring these
diseases that were once eliminated in
the United States by simply eating human
waste and them biting you with putting
it in your body.
This is exactly why I bought a month
ago.
We started seeing,
you know,
this disease pop up.
People cannot explain it.
some people died.
Tuberculosis,
for example,
is exploding in the United States.
The top four states with tuberculosis
are California.
Over 500 cases.
Florida,
Texas and New York.
A 16 states are now grappling with
tuberculosis.
It is the fAstest growing disease in
America right now.
They have state of Wisconsin alone has
116 cases of tuberculosis and the
majority of them are drug resistant,
which means it takes six months to treat
a patient and it takes six to eight
months to treat them at the cost of
$150,000
per patient out of our tax dollars.
These are issues we need to talk about.
THese are issues affecting our
communities and that's what I what I
discussed in the book.
So it's not only about national security
per se,
it's why we need to rise in defense of
our culture and our freedoms and what
made America great.
Do you find that the people that are
part of act are diverse politically
because it's.
So.
It's interesting.
I mean I've spent hours with you now and
it's like,
I guess you're a conservative but you're
not,
you're,
you're sort of my kind of conservative.
Right?
Really.
You're like my kind of liberal,
which you,
which you know is half conservative at
this point because everything is so
upside down,
but do you find that you get a real mix
of a political views in the people that
are coming to you?
Oh my gosh,
look with our organizations.
I mean we Have everybody,
people that put their differences aside
and came together for the safety and
security of America and preserving
whole.
We are as americans and defending our
american values.
Our members are jews,
christians,
buddhists,
hindus,
atheists,
gays,
lesbians.
I mean,
I've got gay chapter leaders,
chapter leaders.
We've got to everybody.
People like you and I and everybody else
that put.
Yeah,
you know,
people may not agree on every single
social issues,
but people agree on a lot of things that
make us americans because we love each
other as americans.
We respect eacH other as americans and
we want to defend our country and the
principles that made it great.
And so that's why we work together.
And it's like I said,
it's such a shame that no people,
you know,
I never thought I would be.
I,
you know,
I will be called the conservative or you
will be called the conservative,
but you know what?
As far as the leftist concern,
right now,
you and I are conservatives.
That doesn't matter that you are a
married gay man.
You're a conservative.
Welcome to the new conservatism and you
know,
this is why when Donald Trump talks
about nationalism,
we aren't nationalist country.
We are,
we are standing up as a nation to fight
what makes America great patriotic
american.
You know the patriotism that we have in
America.
They don't have another countries of the
world.
You go to Australia,
you don't see the australian flag flying
everywhere you go to england.
You don't see that in british flag
everywhere.
We noticed that when I was in here.
Now that you're traveling worldwide,
what makes America so unique is this
nationalism that brings us altogether
our love for country.
People go to baseball games and we
played tHe national anthem.
You know,
they don't do that in other parts of the
world.
They don't play the national anthem
before games.
We take it for granted and now
everybody's upset with the president
because he's talking about american
nationalism.
What?
What brings us together?
They need to travel to Australia,
go to Canada,
go to Germany,
attend a a football,
think they don't play the national
anthem.
It's not like the United States.
THat's what he was referring to.
We're talking about our nationalism.
What brings us together as americans,
our americanism.
He could have used a different word.
Americanism.
So the word,
so the left will not feel offended,
but that's what he was talking about.
Pretty fair.
they would have offended either way.
They would have been offended either
way.
I feel I should give you the chance to
close this with this speech as epic as
your last,
although you've done about five of them
here in the last hour,
but do you want to give me a closing
statement that will be memorable.
Footprints in history are not made
sitting down.
Countries cannot be saved by Hashtags
and tweets.
We need to stand up and put some sweat
equity into saving our country,
but thankfully we don't have to freeze
and valley forge like our founding
fathers in the snow,
waiting to see if we still have a
country the next day.
What we can do right now with our
activism is come together and get
together at a coffee shop,
a sipping our cup of chinos,
meeting likeminded,
great americans who love America,
who believe in american exceptionalism,
who believe in safe,
secure border hope,
believe in having law and order in our
country who believe in respecting our
police,
who believe in honoring our military
whole believe in cherishing the memories
and,
and acknowledging the freedom that we
have at the sacrifices that our military
have paid to give us the freedoms that
we have today.
You know,
wHen we visit other countries and you
have visited France and you go to
normandy and you see the graves of
americans and normandy,
you sit back and you know that this
american brave soldiers left their home
and went overseas leading their life on
the line to fight for freedom and for
justice.
And for the american values,
if you don't want to call them
judeochristian values,
american values,
so the rest of the world and experience
the freedom that we have.
THe previous generation was willing to
cross oceans and go die over there to
protect the same freedoms that we have
here at home and give them to other
people.
The least we can do is activate here in
our home,
in the United States of America and come
together and stand together and face
those naysayers and those who slap
labels on us,
at least they're not shooting bullets at
us all day.
All they're saying is he's a racist or
she's a racist or she's a white suv.
Promises,
but we can come together to save our
country together.
And that's the beauty.
It's people like you and I coming
together and looking into each other's
eyes and really being so excited to see
each other again and read together again
as americans,
as different as we are,
but we come together and we love each
other and respect what each other does
to save this country.
And that's what America is all about.
I encourage people to rise,
rise and defensive,
judeo christian values and freedom.
get the book,
read it,
share it with their friends,
get multiple copies,
put them in public libraries.
We need to educate and go to act for
America that own and by the way,
we named the organization,
act for America,
not think about America now,
which for America,
pray for America.
You can do all that,
but without acting,
nothing happens.
You are the real deal,
bridgette,
a friend I love or the racist bigot of
the day.
then I will gladly be thrown in that
bucket with you.
A use case.
People don't know guys.
The link to rise is right down below and
buy it and put it in libraries and all
that
more appreciate and you can follow her
on twitter.
It's act.
Bridgette.